any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
audience today we are speaking with a
man who is uh
i call him the biggest mensch in the
multiverse it is uh lord martin reese
astronomer royale a friend of the arthur
c clarke center for human imagination
uh long time influence inspiration and
really
in some ways the father of my field of
cmb
polarization as i'll explain as we go on
but first today
uh martin welcome are you in cambridge
right now
i'm at home in cambridge and uh great to
be with you brown it's great to
to be with you i always cherish our
conversations today we're going to be
talking uh
first about your book on the future uh
which came out a couple of years ago
but the reason for this is that lord
reece
was one of the recipients of the arthur
c clarke foundation
awards recently for the future along
with ted chang
and fabian fabiola giannatti of cern
and it was an occasion to get get
some time with him i could not resist so
first of all
congratulations on winning the arthur c
clarke foundation award
thank you very much and that was about
the future and i think
your book is was really kind of a
cornerstone theme
i read it when it came out i reread it
and
uh and i really do want to talk about it
usually uh
lord martin we we review the first thing
i always say is i judge all books by
their cover
and this cover is perhaps the most
sparse cover i've ever seen
so we won't talk about the cover but i
do want to talk about the title
you are known for provocative titles and
in some cases your titles get changed
depending on where they're printed so
first of all
can you explain what is the meaning of
on the future and the prospects for
humanity
what drove you to create a book like
this um
well as you mentioned i did have a book
about 15 years ago
which i called our final century with a
question mark
which uh raised issues about long-term
threats the publishers cut out a
question mark
but when it was published in america the
title was changed to our final
hour and i interpret that as being that
you guys want instant gratification and
a reverse
violation and this was a more innocuous
uh title but uh the theme of the book uh
is that um
we are in a very special century and i
guess that's what we'll be discussing
yeah um before we begin i do want to
mention
uh this um honorific that you maintain
which is uh astronomer royal and and you
once told me
and in fact you you say it in the book
but i'm going to tell it the way you
told me
that most of the time people think your
job is to read the queen her horoscope
and i i love that line and i'm hoping
you'll tell me what i am
uh but i but i but i once went to a
horoscope reader when i was dating my
uh soon-to-be wife of uh 14 or so years
from now
i should remember that uh but we were
dating and she wanted to see
some you know astrologer and the
astrologer asked me what's your sign and
i said well you know i'm a gemini i
think
and she said okay well this is going to
happen to you there's going to be you
know fluctuations in the stock market
um there'll be uncertainty in the middle
east and uh and then at the end i said
you know what
i'm actually born in september isn't
that a virgo
and the astrologer said yeah but it
doesn't matter your horoscope's the same
and i wonder you talk a little bit about
in the book for the first time i feel
like we're
i have a kindred spirit in that you're
kind of um a little not antagonistic
towards karl popper
but the notion of the demarcation
hypothesis and how that has become
synonymous with what is good science
i wonder could you speak a little about
your views on popperism i talked to
lenny suskin about a month ago
and he called it the paparazzi and don't
get obsessed with the paparazzi
tell me what do you what are your
feelings about what constitutes science
in the context of astrology
astronomy etc well i mean i think it's
got to be something which uh
is subject to empirical tests and which
is a
progressive et cetera and astrology
isn't because it's a
mumbo-jumbo and you can't really test it
and hasn't survived
the test have been done um but um the
proper
um scenario which of course has been
very popular i mean
most philosophers are unduly
contemptuous
of so most scientists are unduly
contemptuous
of philosophy hawking in particular was
outrageously
dismissive of philosophy completely
unjustifiably um but um
the philosophers who scientists have
liked include
two i guess in particular and one of
them
is karl popper and his uh
idea was that to be a scientific
statement
it's got to be a refutable you can't
refute it and it's not science
and there's something in that because uh
to take
an example i mean um reincarnation
which is an idea held by many people but
uh
there's no way in which you could refute
it to their satisfaction
so that's the reason why reincarnation
is not science um
but refutation is of course an important
part of science but it's not infallible
i mean
i quote an example in my book um that um
supposing that the michaelson morley
experiment that's the experiment but
shows that uh
light goes at the same speed um at any
time in the year even though the earth
is going around
um if that had been done in the um
16th or 17th century it would have been
used to refute copernicus
because people would say that clearly
through the earth does not move
um and so that is an example showing how
you can't be convinced of refutation
unless you're convinced of the um
grounding
of that particular argument so it's
fuzzier than
poppa tried to maintain but nonetheless
he
pointed out that if you can't find any
evidence against
a theory and reincarnation example of
that
then it's not really science yes i want
to run by you an example
another example and get your impressions
about it and that is
the proof that the earth is not round
from the reddening of sunlight at sunset
or equivalently in the cosmic microwave
background uh image
or the observatory that's behind me in
my zoom background
is the very thick optical density of the
atmosphere which is indicative
of a flat planar atmosphere which means
that the earth must be a
flat planar object yeah so
yes and i think and i wanted to ask you
this for a while i've asked it of
sir roger penrose and uh and and others
and that is about you know falsification
um and and and and popper that i have
noted sort of a an envy you know freud
would probably call it a
mathematician envy uh as as as his want
and it's ironic
popper wasn't talking about cosmology or
astronomy he was actually a proponent of
the steady state as you know for
for some time but but he was he was
irritated at astrologers and even
psychoanalysis as you
talk about in on the future but um
but the but the impression that i get is
that we physicists
are um antagonized or perhaps we are
envious of mathematicians because
girdle showed what constitutes
mathematics
but there's no equivalent for what
constitutes physics and and i wonder
is that because physics is by nature
provisional
and yeah and it is subject to imperial
update i mean isaac asimov once said
you know the if you think the earth is
flat you're wrong if you think the earth
is a perfect sphere
you're also wrong but you're less wrong
than if you think it's flat
so i wonder do we feel as physicists
inadequate
envious perhaps tension and anxiety
because we
can't refute things so easily as say
girdle showed in mathematics
um well that may be true but of course
you're asking the obverse of the most
common question which is
physics envy which many other scientists
have because
compared to most other sciences which
deal with things more complicated than
the
single atoms and molecules and newtonian
gravity
uh physics is simple and straightforward
and uh therefore
it is easier to get clear-cut results in
physics
than in most other sciences now subject
matter of
physics is simpler so normally people
say that
it's the other subjects that are and of
course
the way in which you can gain confidence
in a science
even when it's not one that lends itself
to clear-cut reputations
is if a whole set of arguments
embeds together in a consistent story i
mean i think if you look at something
like a
continental drift for instance um the
plate tectonics that was an idea um
and what was convincing about that was
it explained
lots of hidden two surprising and
disconnected facts they all
put together and uh darwinian evolution
is another case
there's a you could refute it i suppose
if you found some
um human bones on the in the lower
strata dinosaur bones or something like
that so you could refute it
but um most people uh would say that the
strength of darwinism is the huge volume
of data
which it links together in a consistent
way it offers a framework for
interpreting so
uh i think science is a search for
patterns and unification
in diverse data and uh yeah that reminds
me
you know i sometimes joke that my house
is so old
that uh there's a nuclear reactor and
it's covered up by some dinosaur bones
and
that just blows people's minds but um
speaking of girdle
allegedly he believed until his deathbed
according to some young person who
emails me all the time about
the rotating universe hypothesis that
the universe uh
is rotating in at least girdle's
conception of the cosmo
cosmogeny and and then even on his
deathbed he said
that he wondered is the universe still
rotating
and and you must get a lot of these
emails i get a lot of them
i was joking with um with adam reese uh
who
uh was on the podcast a couple of times
this year and
i said you know adam i get all these
emails you know as i'm sure you do
einstein was wrong i can prove it if you
help me with the maths because i'm not
so good at maths
uh but if you help me i'll share a
portion of the nobel prize with you
i get those emails and adam said yeah
how do you think i got my nobel prize
so what do you make of the fact that
there's so many people that are so
interested in proving you know stephen
hawking
right or wrong or proving einstein but
no one really comes up and says i think
boltzmann was wrong and
or maxwell was wrong and maxwell was
actually wrong about many things but
um but nobody seems they always seem to
want to take down einstein
what is that compulsion that people have
in europe
i think you know they want to attack the
biggest targets don't they and uh
einstein is one but uh darwin's one and
but i also have had uh letters from
people saying newton was wrong
that's good because i was a head of
newton's college and uh
president of sideways i agree so there's
people who are slightly more original
who want to go back and prove newton
wrong
not mean because i was wrong but of
course
showing darwin was wrong is of course
the much more popular pursuit
yes yes of course uh you know of course
newton was wrong uh in some ways but uh
he
he hasn't retracted his uh some of his
blunders and alchemy
and in theology and i guess that brings
me to another point
i often find that um the most famous
scientists on earth
right now to the extent that anybody
knows a scientist
they might think that stephen hawking
and hawkins that i usually say
i want to write to you about stephen
hawkins and i said first you have to
spell his name right
uh but or the nobel prize with an le
at the end uh but i want to know um you
know when people
think about um theories or theater or
scientists rather they think about
theorists they think about brian greene
they think about michio kaku stephen
hawking
uh they might think about you why is it
that there's such an
over appreciation in my opinion an
overabundance
of of kind of association with
scientists as being theorists
such as yourself um
well i suppose they like to think of the
idea of
the great mind understanding of the
universe etc but of course it is um
uh a very misleading view of science
because i mean uh
um if we look at our science um then
it's owed at least 95 percent to
advances in instrumentation isn't it
um uh um we are now wise and aristotle
was in fact we're less wise than he was
and the only reason we made progress is
by having better data really and uh
and so it's an it's a subject which is
led by
observation and the observations only
improve
because of uh better um instruments
and now better computations as well so
um
the the armchair theorist um of course
gets exaggerated acclaim because
uh there are very few um branches of
science where
he or she makes a role comparable to
that of experimenter
and i'm curious you said that we are
less wise than aristotle i
i feel like i don't know something that
aristotle said
uh from heavy bodies fall faster than
light bodies to
you know notions about this the
steadiness of the universe's endurance
um i don't know a single physical
principle that he was right about
he was brilliant when he came to
philosophy and and social security
i'm saying this uh um he wasn't
he wasn't right but as an intellect of
range
um he was clearly very high iq indeed
yes
and that brings me to another question
tomorrow night i'll be speaking with
giant narlikar who's
uh one a wonderful figure and i'm sure
did you overlap with giant and fred he
was about
three or four years ahead of me but of
course i uh
i did overlap with him he was working
with fred hoyle
as a postdoc when i was a graduate
student
and of course i've seen him ever since
and in fact i um i i did um
a zoom uh public lecture to yuka
in puna which he set up just a month ago
oh wonderful oh well i'll send you his
uh
send him your regards and vice versa
after i talk to him but i'm curious
he still maintains in aspects of the
steady
state dear the quasi-steady state
theories veracity
and it brings me to my next question
that you know i've seen a lot of times
and you know
from being one of my most prominent
endorsers
of my book losing the nobel prize that
you know we've had to retract many
experimental results that achieve great
great notoriety and great public
attention i always joke that the
announcement occurs on you know above
the fold
uh on page one of the new york times or
or
the san diego union tribune here and uh
but then the retraction
if it's ever published occurs you know
on the page 17b of the saturday morning
edition that nobody reads
um and so i've seen a lot of experiments
retracted
i have yet to see a theory retracted you
know just fully
divorce even jeff burbidge who i have
the honor of having his office here at
uc san diego
you know him very well and he was um and
he was he was the holder of my office
before i moved in
after his uh death in 2010 but um but he
went to his grave believing in the
veracity of the steady state theory too
so what what is it
about theories that become so
um so endeared you know to their to
their conjecturers
that and you you've had many of these
instances of creating theories so
first what is it about a theory that
holds such permanence in the heart of
his or her of its creator
well you know i think what you're saying
is one category a person is
is like that um and uh and they they do
get obsessed with the theory
and indeed an experimenter who spent 10
years building an instrument
um is going to uh probably have an
exaggerated feeling for the importance
of what it will discover
otherwise it won't be motivated so it's
not surprising that people get committed
to a theory
and of course as backflank famously said
that uh um
theories survive until all their
proponents die off right
that's true of some of them um but
people do change but
it is very interesting because um uh if
i could mention someone else my
my phd advisor was dennis sharma and uh
he
he was someone who um he
he was the um most prominent believer in
the steady state theory
apart from its fear inventors this is
bondi golden hoyle invented
and he was a great supporter of it when
i started in 1964
as a graduate student he was a believer
in the steady state theory
yes and uh i think i helped to talk him
out of it because
one of my student papers was with him
which was some of the new evidence
against steady state
um but he was someone who had to believe
something strongly
in order to be motivated to work on it
he was like a lawyer
and he would have this thing so what did
we say if they find that you know and
etc so he had to become committed but
if i look at my own attitude i think i'm
genuinely not like that at all
i'm quite happy to work at the same time
on two contradictory theories
on the grounds that i want to know the
answer and by
running the two horses against each
other and seeing if one stumbles
then that's the way to decide which is
the best so um i'm
very happy because i want to know the
answer um
to explore two theories that's enough
motivation for me to know the answer
whereas there are some people and dennis
sharma's example
had to believe that something was almost
certainly correct in order to follow up
its consequences
and as you say those who've got a great
commitment
to a theory um are um going to be
those who are reluctant to give it up
and if you go back to nalica
he was a student of fred hoyle and uh
fred hoyle actually
um he he he was such an inventive man he
had lots of theories
and he didn't really have all that much
stake in any one of them i don't think
so
um he he enjoyed the debate and there
was another debate going on
um at this time which was the first
evidence against steady state which came
before the micro background um from the
um
distribution um of the um uh radio
sources uh
quasars and um martin reil
who was a radio radio strummer um
built an interferometer and he showed
evidence that there were more
of these exploding galaxies as well
which now called quasars
um far away than there are nearby
implying that there were more in the
past than there are now
um and this would be in the system with
steady state because
at all times the universe should look
the same whereas it is consistent with a
evolving universe and um there was a
long debate between
uh hoyle and ryle which got a lot of
public interest in the uk
um but it was interesting because um
hoyle was someone who enjoyed debate and
um and he didn't get upset by it whereas
ryle got
really really upset if his work was
criticized
and to be fair he was right yeah um but
the point was that he'd actually
built this the world's first um
interferometer uh using apa
since his techniques and he'd built the
thing himself
and worked for years and years and so he
got a huge investment
in this project so it's not surprising
that he was uh
um going to be rather committed to its
results and uh
to have them sort of uh disparaged by an
armchair theorist was upsetting for him
yeah and of course he uh in some ways
had a a later laugh
although maybe not the last laugh with
uh the recipient of the
nobel prize and was he the astronomer
royal i forgot
um he he he was retired because
the history of that job is that until
1960 it was the person who ran the
greenish observatory
yes um uh which was a real job but then
when that became a museum um and people
started going to hawaii and chile to the
observations
they kept the title but kept it as an
honorary title
and uh indeed uh martin reil was
hold of that i believe margaret burbidge
my late colleague here at uc san diego
was
she was director of rgo the royal
grounds observatory but she wasn't
astronomical um and then that caused her
in some ways beneficially for me to come
to san diego eventually and start my
department so
thank the uh thank the astronomer royal
recipients or deciders for that for me
if you will
so just one last thing about you know
these these theories i wonder just
speculating
you know when i build an experiment it's
not me building an experiment we
literally have 300 people working on the
simon's observatory and pictured behind
me
whereas a theory can be done by one or
two people
and so it's much more associated with
one's identity i would say i mean i
bleed and i sweat and i cry over all my
experiments
but you know if it's a it has to be a
collaborative endeavor it's too
big to be done individually whereas i
think you can still do theory today
and i want to uh circle back in in a
2018
interview you said one of your character
traits
which i take as a good trait is is that
you're impatient
and you like to multitask in the sense
that you
like to work on many different things at
once and in some sense you remind me of
jim simons and that you like to hedge
your head your risk your downside risk
and of course that's a lot of what this
book
on the future is about we'll get to that
in just a second it's a little hard to
see
uh but um but getting back to uh i want
to go back to 1968
now when you came up with the idea that
the universe might be
paul the cmb might be polarized and i
want to remind our listeners and what
viewers
that this is only three years after the
discovery of the cosmic microwave
background itself
and at this point the anisotropies of
the microwave background had not been
understood or measured in any way even
the dipole had not been measured
and here was lord reese as i believe it
was part of was it part of your phd
thesis martin
that was a postdoc as a postdoc so you
conjectured that it might be polarized
if the universe were behaving in an
interesting way
and because sometimes i feel like even
incorrect theories can provide
very important touchstones for
experimentalists like myself to pursue
even though the ultimately the cause of
the polarization in your model
was not uh was not the correct one in
that i believe you
ascribed a potential polarization to an
anisotropic expansion
of the universe expanding as a
quadrupole
distribution that with a quadripolar
asymmetry in its expansion rate i
believe technically
that that would produce a uh the
conditions necessary for polarization
we now know that's not what causes the
polarization but nevertheless it wasn't
discovered for another
32 years so you spoke once about you
know kind of being impatient and then
moving on so
i want to say is there a value in
theories that ultimately might not be
right but they can be used to empower
experimentalists like me
well i think so and just to expand a bit
on that um
the reason i did this was that there was
a great deal of interest at that time
in an isotropic models where the
expansion was
fast you know faster in one direction in
a permanent direction
and there was something called the mix
master universe which expanded fast one
way than the other
and the motive for this uh in the late
60s
um was um uh provided by
charlie misner who's a theorist at
maryland
and the argument was it was it was
called the horizon problem
that uh um different parts of the
universe in the standard model
uh don't causally connect early on and
this is a
um one of the things that the
inflationary idea solved
20 years later but uh over in the uk we
were aware of the horizon problem
ten years at least before alan guth was
um and the
arguments being discussed then were that
the
um expansion may be an isotopic and the
russians had ideas like this
and so um i was familiar with these
models for anastrop universes
and uh in those models it's fairly easy
to see
um that the radiation will be polarized
um uh and then i said at the at the end
of my paper that uh
you get this for other kinds of
variations but i was only thinking at
that time
of these uh models where the entire
hubble expansion was fast in some
directions
than others yeah and i wonder even in
the quasi-steady state cosmology they
had this notion of the sea
field which you know continually created
matter
so as to preserve the density and the
overall appearance which
i remember jeff burbidge talking to me
about was you know presaging
some notions of the constancy of of of
dark energy
disputed that i i do take a little
credit well because once i gave a talk
about our experiment polar bear which is
a precursor to the simon's array
and jeff was in the audience and usually
when a cosmologist would come to speak
here at uc san diego
jeff would kind of haramph and say oh
cosmology really you know
and it's great booming a british lion
voice
but this time i showed a picture of our
detectors and he said
and i couldn't believe this he said wow
that is really
cool and i just thought you know he's
gone californian
i mean to talk like a surfer uh but
there was something about
experiment that he really loved and and
and of course he
he wasn't an observer he was he was a
theorist margaret was the observer of
the duo
and she was a titanic figure in
astronomy uh and
you know as you kind of hinted to before
plank uh about uh you know theories
advancing he said something also you
know
theory or science advances one funeral
at a time
and yet i still believe there are
valuable contributions even in these
things like gnarler car and
and so forth but the problem is somebody
needs to tap them on the shoulder so to
speak and say
you have this amazing gifted mind but i
think it could be used in other
directions and and i want to turn to
that now
i've done a lot of i'm sorry were you
going to say something
i was going to say i mean going back to
narlikar
um hoyle was very keen and
the thing is very sad yeah was that um
gnarly car was a almost complete
contemporary
of uh of hawking and carter etc
in the same building and uh fred hoyle
never appreciated the work which uh
hawking and caster were doing
classic work on black holes um and uh
narlikar had such great loyalty to fred
hoyle
because he never got involved in this
whereas he was would be fully able to do
uh important work in the nato black
holes you know
but whereas uh all the other young
people
followed the lead of roger penrose and
used his techniques to explore
black holes and this was all done in the
late 60s um with the
this group in cambridge playing a big
role um nalika i think out of loyalty to
fred
never got involved yeah and if you look
at his later books
he talks about uh um cosmology and he
talks about the micro backgrounds and
all that but he has a chapter at the end
where he will uh feel out of loyalty
he's got to put in
a chapter on steady state university yes
i know
i'm going to talk to him about that very
issue uh tomorrow
when he comes on the show and yes
they're always you know there's
problems and speculations on cosmology
one of his more recent books
and some of it uh it's it's curious it's
it's it's um
it's novel to hear at least from my
perspective that hoyle was at least
maybe less loyal or less passionate
because i always had the impression that
he was
more embittered than than narlikar but
it but it sounds like
and i'll talk to a giant about this
tomorrow but but the question of you
know whether or not you know the loyalty
to a theory and loyalty to an idea
and that takes me to my next question
about the proliferation
of theories of everything so i've had a
lot of conversations over the last six
months with
folks like stephen wolfram eric
weinstein
i'm going to be speaking with a with
julian barbour
as well as garrett lisi and others with
new claim new theories of everything
yes as well as um you know people uh
that are in more traditional fields like
i talked to sheldon glashow and i've
talked to frank wilceck
about this provocative question that i
like to pose to my
uh honored guests or my aunt the guests
that honor me i don't know
i do honor you uh but the point is uh do
we need a theory of everything and
the reason harkens back to what you just
mentioned about about hawking and
penrose and i talked
i asked this of sir roger as well i said
i always
find that it's kind of like this
uroburus the snake that eats its own
tail
we say we need a theory of quantum
gravity because we don't understand the
properties of singularities
at the center of black holes or perhaps
a singularity at the origin of time
itself and the so-called big bang and
the question of you know
these things must be unified because we
need a theory of gravity that's
quantized
because we can't understand
singularities uh otherwise
now going back to our earlier point
about about
um falsification or maybe even
empiricism
we can't ever access the singularity at
the core of a black hole
we don't know if it's real we don't know
its entity we don't know its nature its
properties
it's it's firewalled off literally i
mentioned this to lenny suskin
and he sort of agreed that actually to
him the most interesting part of the
black hole is not the singularity
it's the event horizon or what he calls
the stretched horizon
and then talking to sir roger similarly
about black holes but also about the
origin
of the universe which you know i'm sure
he doesn't believe in a
quantum you know bing bang a singularity
in time and neither does my friend and
your friend
uh paul steinhardt so my question is
if god i know you don't believe and you
don't actively affirm a belief in god
but god hands me a letter
you know and says brian read this to
lord martin and it says there was no
singular big bang it's more complicated
than that it's either classical or
eons or or what have you or bouncing
and um and and then they also say there
is no
way to observe god says you can't
observe what's happening at the
center of a black hole so in that case
if you knew there were no
real examples that we could ever probe
would you still say we need
a theory of everything well i think uh
you're wrong in assuming we could never
have any evidence for it
because um it's clear as you say that
we could understand the big bang better
if we could understand a context where
clearly gravity is important
and quantum theory is important for
things very high density etc
now the problem is we can't do
experiments
um in those regimes but if we in
principle had a theory
which could describe the conditions
right at the beginning of the universe
and inside a black hole and if that same
theory
predicted the masses of all the
elementary particles
and the relative strengths and all the
fundamental numbers of physics
then we'd know there's something in it
and it's a
heresy to think that you have to be able
to test all the consequent theory
you have to be able to test enough
consequences to get confidence
in it and then you take serious
predictions when you can't observe so
to go back to black holes we take what
einstein's theory says about the inside
of a black hole
seriously even though we can't observe
it there
because we've been able to verify
einstein's theory in many other contexts
outside the black hole and so likewise
we could have a theory
um which does give us a
deep insight into the big bang and
unification and incidentally into dark
energy
which i think is going to need a similar
sort of theory
and we could gain confidence in it if it
manages to explain the standard model
and all the
arbitrary numbers in that and if it
gives formula for those then
that'll be a huge achievement and we
take the serious seriously but um having
said all that
um the the phrase theory of everything
is a very unfortunate phrase because
what we're going to talk about now and
what i'm saying we
would like to have is a theory that
unifies the four forces of nature as it
were
unifies the gravity for the very large
with the
very small and so boris when the snake
eats his tail
it can cope with that that juxtaposition
as it were that's right but of course
quantity theory of everything is
misleading because if you think of all
the other sciences
biology chemistry everything else um
none of them are
held up to the slightest extent by the
lack of
this theory right quantum theory or even
nuclear physics
is pretty irrelevant uh to to chemists
and
and biologists and so the main
challenges in science
or some of the main challenges in
science are the chances of complexity
the biological world um and uh and so
um even if we accept that
everything is frederick's equation etc
that's not the way we understand them
and i think this sort of um uh extreme
reductionism is very misleading
uh let me give an example of this um of
course lots of people think that uh
living things have special vitalism and
all that you know and something's
unlocked mr roger and
uh stuart hamroff have this uh yes yes
um but the main point is that every
every science uh we go from physics to
chemistry
to cell biology to organisms um all the
way up to societies
each science at each level
has its own irreducible concepts and let
me take a simple example it doesn't
involve vitalism
it's less controversial and fluid
mechanics it's a well-defined subject
okay the
um where the concepts are turbulence
viscosity etc and you
work out and understand how waves break
and all
all that and when flows go unstable and
it's a serious subject and all that
but the people who work on that subject
they treat
the liquid the water as a
fluid continuum
they don't care it's h2o and
even if you had a massive computer which
could solve schweitzer's equation for
10 to the 30th atoms in
in in a flowing stream
then that solution wouldn't give you any
insight
the inside comes from the level and so
as you go one step up from atomic
physics you get things like fluid
mechanics
which are scientists of their own right
which have their own concepts
and no one denies that
um uh a flow of water
is a solution for eric's equation but
it's not helpful to be able to
do that even you can solve the equation
and of course um
most would say that's true of living
things as well yeah
yeah i mean there's a famous quote or
phrase attributed to dirac
you know he said something like you know
my equation explains
most of chemistry and most of uh
all of chemistry and most of biology and
i always thought you know
in ninth grade biology class you know if
i say let me let me get the relativistic
schrodinger equation out and solve it so
i can dissect this frog
some big problems well the frog would
have bigger problems i want to take a
quick pause
just what's that
it doesn't give us any insight that's
right yes it's it's true but not useful
uh i want to give um a little break to
recognize our guest
lord martin reese author of many books
including just six numbers
on the future our final hour slash
century whichever comes first i guess
uh and want to thank my listeners and
viewers i want to encourage you to like
and subscribe and
and comment on the video and uh please
leave a review on itunes or wherever
you're listening to this
uh so that we can continue to get great
guests like lord martin reese who
just having such a ball with this is
such a a wonderful
delicious treat uh for me so uh like
going back to this this question of you
know
complexity and things that are
complicated so to speak
i always make the distinction like
getting a you know a grain
uh putting a grain of sand on a pile you
know that's complexity
but it's not really complicated so you
can describe it in a very short amount
of
text and you go through and hear this
russian gentleman whose name escapes me
right now
but he has he has a rubric or a way
of delineating and calculating
complexity as the shortest computer code
needed to describe that system so a
system of 10 to the
you know 28th particles in this giant
sand piles very
you know a lot of particles but they're
the underlying forces as
as as you were just saying uh lord
martin are
very simple to understand and yet we
have examples of potential theories of
everything
for example stephen wolframs is very
reminiscent of the game of life which
you talk about as being
simple in some sense but you know having
exhibiting complexity
almost reminiscent of life but i wonder
is
maybe and i asked stephen about this and
i confess i didn't fully understand his
answer
but i said well if it's truly a theory
of everything does that mean
it's going to get out you know bell's
inequality
is it going to get out you know epr is
it going to get out um
you know this collapse of the wave
function or is it
going to unify su 2 with with su-3
and you want what is it going to do and
he said
yes i don't understand how something
that is like cellular automata
like the game of life can exhibit the
principles that
that originate these things and and i
want to take you back to
um to these earlier kinds of of
suppositions about
the multiverse and how the universe
could begin and they always start with
the laws of physics and the question i
have is where do those come from
in in these in these models is it
necessary for a theory of everything
to explain you know bootstrap how it
came about
or is that asking too much as we don't
do of biology as you said
um well i mean some people would
like to be able to show that our
universe is
uniquely self-consistent in a way and
that the uh
the laws um uh constrain it
in such a way if we almost predict the
way it is some people i think maybe
roger penrose
thinks that's true but i mean i think
what willful is doing it's not
conceptually different from what
everyone thinks which is that uh
very very complex things like animals um
can be
produced by simple simple laws and
that's all that uh conway was doing with
his game of life he'd point that you
can't get
surprising complexity by um uh iterating
very simple
laws and that's qualitatively the same
as what happens in
in most of chemistry isn't it um
theory does incorporate
quantum theory completely i don't know
um
it may be a different theory so
now going through uh your book i noted
um
well first of all i want to ask you are
you a pessimistic
optimist or an optimistic pessimist um
well i mean i
i think i would say i'm a optimist about
the power of technology
but a pessimist about politics and human
nature
in that i i think the gap between
what technology would allow us to do and
not likely happen
is getting wider and wider and that's
indictment of our ethics into our
politics
and uh do you feel that we're there's
any hope for
out out overcoming this or as carl sagan
said you know it's dangerous to have a
society whose
technological capacity exceeds its
wisdom and how to use that technology
um well it is dangerous and uh uh
carl said that and uh um h.g wells said
that uh
um the census is going to be a race
between education and catastrophe
and that's that's true um so uh i
i don't know how it would pan out um but
uh
the world is getting much more difficult
to govern obviously
i always used to joke and i think i
asked this of sir roger penrose the
first time i talked to him but
um if somebody oh no i asked this of
freeman dyson uh that's right
and i said freeman if somebody because
he was kind of uh contrarian as you know
and i said uh you know if somebody tells
you i've got good news and bad news
which do you want to hear first and his
answer was kind of uh surprising but i
want to know first from you is i don't
want to bias the experiment so
if i come up to you and say lord martin
i've got good news and i've got bad news
which do you want to hear first
yes i think i want to hear the bad news
first
i think he did too i think he viewed uh
wanting to
minimize the number of surprises but
also have the extra time to deal with
the consequences of the bad news
um what about like uh somebody says uh
lord martin we've got this wonderful
movie you gotta see it because at the
end
you know they wanna spoil it for you do
you wanna know that do you wanna know
the spoil or do you wanna have the
surprise yourself but it's a movie that
was a surprise
okay but if it's the stock market i
assume you'd like to know the insights
so getting back a little bit to um to
you know theory versus experiment which
you know is something that we explore a
lot on the into the impossible podcast
i have this notion that you know theory
and even theorists
are abundant and uh whereas experiments
are
extremely hard to do and you talk about
the lhc in this book you talk a little
bit about the super collider
you know which is canceled and i brought
this up to barry barish i said barry it
was good thing for you that the super
collider was cancelled because he was
working as one of the leaders of the
super conducting super collider
in 1993 was canceled and uh it ended up
putting him on a path to go
to work for on ligo whereas if he had
where he eventually won
uh third share of the nobel prize in
2017 and
and yet if he had stayed with the super
collider and they had discovered the
higgs
that we know for sure that he wouldn't
have won the nobel prize because no
experimentalist got any share
in the nobel prize for that year so i
said it was good for you and he said i
don't like to play games like that
and we moved on to other topics but i
want to ask you when do you when do you
stop a theory in other words i know sort
of
that we lose we win in experimental
physics such as the cosmic microwave
background we win very slowly
with time we only win as the square root
of time
and that we have to take four times as
much data for many four times many years
to get a 2x improvement on the signal to
noise
when do you know when to turn off a
theory or turn off an experiment is
there any kind of rubric that you can
help us with to make these decisions
because they're
only getting more and more complex
expensive and demanding of resources
most of which being the intellect of
young people
yes well i mean i think in terms of
experiments
um you know the follow-up to the lhc nhc
as hc as you can see as you know
and it's going to be delayed by
i would guess two decades we don't know
um
and that's because people realize that
uh there are other
techniques of ligo and underwater
neutrino experiments and all these
things which can do exciting
science um in related areas much more
cheaply
um so so i think uh experiments uh do
get more and more expensive and at some
stage you have to
jump off and do something else but of
course theory is very cheap you just
need to
to feed someone and then they can go on
um coming up with with theories
and i think um there's a question of
whether
um if you're a theorist um do you want
to
um you work on some popular theory
um or do you want to strike out and come
up with your own theory
and of course um i think we're seeing a
tendency now
um that uh more people are coming up
with sort of
rather more baroque and exotic theories
um that's because
um i thought i mean string theory is 40
years old now
um and it's not clear
it's on the right lines or progressing
so there are lots of young people
in that sort of field
and they want to do something
distinctive and different so what
happens is you get a
a variety of uh rather baroque variants
of any theory
that are going to be developed and this
is just psychology people want to make
their mark
et cetera but uh um i think
it's not very satisfaction if you have a
theory and
no one else takes it seriously at all
but it's also unhealthy
if there's a bandwagon effects and too
many people are working on a particular
theory and
i think that's certainly was true of
string theory 10 or 20 years ago it's
perhaps
somewhat less true now yeah i want to
gently i want to gently
oh no kidding can you hear me okay
martin
do you hear me martin yes okay good
um so in the uh towards the conclusion
of the book
you make a very provocative statement in
some sense about
where scientists uh should fit in and i
want to push back provocatively as well
uh so you say that physicists don't get
better with age
they burn out and first of all i think
there is kind of a misconception that
um that you know you do your best work
by age 30.
that may be true in mathematics um and i
taught this conversation with jim simons
about this
uh as well as others but in experimental
physics you only get
better in other words talking to barry
barish he has
brilliant ideas that will benefit the
simon's observatory and
and we recruit people elder statesmen
and women
in this we actually have a committee of
the most distinguished men and women on
earth in my opinion
some very young and some older and uh
and an experiment at least i feel that
this statement is not true
that scientists do get better with age
it's just maybe
they're not as creative i don't think i
i don't think i denied that i i i said
that uh
um what can go wrong is if the old ones
um don't stick to what they're good at
um
but uh go into some new field and uh and
one think of shockley and fred hoyle
people like that who go into a field
they didn't know anything about
and the reason for that is that uh uh
they're still
um scientifically motivated they want to
understand the world
but they don't any longer get
satisfaction from continuing
on a plateau doing uh the work they're
good at
and benefit from their experience they
want to do something something new
and they overreach themselves
i do say that so if people are happy to
go on on a plateau
and deepen their experience that that's
that's fine
yeah so you do say they won't get better
um in their theories and uh
i do close a contrast um between um
mathematical physicists etc and say
composers because for most
many composers anyway their last works
are their greatest
that's right there's one many scientists
of whom you say that
and the difference is because if you're
a composer
you're influenced by musical styles when
you're young
but thereafter it can be just internal
development where science is an
inherently social activity
and you can't stay up to speed in
science
unless you're able to absorb new
techniques and new ideas
and that's what we become less adept at
as we get older so i think that's that's
a difference but
uh if you stick with what you're good at
um then uh
you can at least stay on the plateau
even though you may not get the higher
peaks
yeah i want to yeah just echo that and
it is true you certainly said that
eminent and elderly
scientists get shielded and i'll come
back to that in just one second but
you made me think of this thing i've
i've been thinking about with regard to
of all things estate planning you know
which is which is not as as
munificent as it might sound but just
that
many things in life are benefit from
what albert einstein
reportedly called the greatest invention
of the human mind
namely compound interest so one of those
i had a guest on bill perkins a few
months about a month ago
and he was saying that you want to
accumulate memories just like money
because your memories go grow and
compound
you know with with time so the earlier
you make a memory the more time it has
to grow
and i feel like that's also true with
many things but including
at least the only discipline i'm
familiar with which is experimental
science that you kind of compound oh
i've seen that problem
with this type of electrical conductor
and we need to use this because it's
going to behave better at high altitudes
and
you do compound and just like compound
interest
you know the last doubling period is is
equal to everything that came before it
uh and that might be why composers their
last work is their best because they're
basically doubling in their last work
everything that they've done up until
that point um
i do want to run is that really true for
many scientists
that's i'm only thinking about
experimental scientists i think that the
point i was counting to make is that
experimental scientists benefit from
wisdom and age you look at
david wilkinson who was doing great work
up until literally the day he died
but then you look at theorists and you
look at uh some theorists and yes they
tend to be doing the same thing they
were doing
when they're 40. you know it has to it
has to have some interest rate
associated with it or it doesn't improve
right
but just like losing weight if you want
to lose weight um you know
10 pounds or five kilos in a year and
you do so
a one percent loss per day you know the
first three months
you're gonna lose less than you know a
quarter of a kilo or something
that you could undo by drinking one
glass of soda
so uh so it's very slow and and it
sneaks up on you and just like you talk
about exponential effects in here
the climate crisis etc which hopefully
we'll get to in the remaining
minutes that we have but um but i want
to
just run a provocative idea by you and
that is
um that i think after a scientist gets
to be
a certain age that maybe their best
contributions could be teaching
and that could free up the younger
researchers uh
you know younger than me i'm not arguing
on my behalf i'm i'm already almost 50
so that that won't apply to me but you
talk about this this problem of
researchers not getting their first
grant until they're 40 and starting
their own
you know and by that time in years gone
by that would be towards the end of
their career
so my provocative thing is that we
should only have theorist teaching
because they certainly know all the
class they know how to teach you know
quantum electrodynamics as well as i do
and maybe better but you know their work
is less dependent on
on getting grants and and and proposing
original research to go
out and i once proposed this to my
colleague kim greist
and he said i'll fight you if you like
he was gonna have a fist fight with me
because he's a theorist and
and i wonder how do you feel about this
provocative idea that that we basically
have the theorists in physics
i don't know about other fields it's for
them to solve but get these older people
that are that are distinguished and
brilliant
but they're not as uh it's not as
critical to them to be out in the field
or collecting research data as it is for
a younger person than me
well i mean i think uh that's one
solution but but i think there are
inherent problems
which are just my book um with academia
now
and uh i was an article recently for
british magazine
and the editor makes up the title and
the title they gave me
was why i'm glad i'm not a young
academic
because what i was saying was that um uh
it's less attractive than it used to be
when i when i was starting and this is
not not the case i mean
um the the worst situation is biomedical
sciences in america
that's where there was a report uh that
you get your first grant
in the nih when you're 42 or 43 um and
um
uh to take an example um the uh
one of the members of that committee um
to the um
ex-president of princeton told me that
she um
um by my agency she got a phd in three
years then a postdoc for three more
years
and then got a grant to set up her own
lab
now that's not possible because the
demography is so different
back back in the 1970s the number of
people was going up
very far so so young outnumbered the old
um
and those quick promotion and um
obviously we can't have continued
exponential growth but
i do think that it's going to have the
consequence
for academic which is very bad and
that's that the most ambitious and
flexible people
won't go into academia or research um
there'll always be the nerdish element
people like me who are going to academia
and uh and pursue some obsession etc but
academia needs to get
its share of flexible talented people
who want to feel they've achieved
something on their own by their 30s
and that was possible in academia um 50
years ago but it's much harder now um
given that
the numbers are stagnant now and it is
aggravated by the fact that in america
you don't have a retiring age that makes
it far worse actually because
people in their 70s are soaking up lots
of the money
but it's going to be bad and what this
is going to mean i think and i
mentioned this in my book is that um
there will be a
stagnation perhaps within academia and
perhaps to be a resurgence
of the independent scientist um because
in 19th century you know
darwin and lord raleigh and people like
that were great men
uh but they weren't an institution they
had the resources they did their own
stuff
and of course we know there are people
now um who make
a lot of money by the time they're 40
and they've got scientific expertise and
i think
there may be more of those people and we
know a few of them but that
would be more um who um uh do very
serious science
um and so things will become perhaps
perhaps
like the 19th century when the best
science is no longer done in
universities
simply because um it's a very hard slog
in university um to uh to get to a
position where you have
uh independence universe could change to
do this
and there's a role for government labs
and things like that in in some areas
but
i think we do have to bear in mind that
if you have a sort of slow promotion
and uh people have to fill in lots of
forms to get grants before they can do
anything
you're going to deter the people you
most want to keep in right
and you talk a lot about in the book
about the potential for a pandemic
um you know to to strike and the
vulnerabilities that we have let's turn
to the
to the book a little bit more in detail
now i i found it so delightful of course
we're talking with lord martin reese
author of on the future and many other
books
uh including uh our cosmic habitat
just six numbers our final hour century
again whichever comes first so i just
devoured this book i've got
every page is highlighted so it's kind
of i lose contrast every
now and then but you you say here on
page
77 pandemics are an ever-present natural
threat
and obviously uh you know this has
crippled a lot of things in the world
but and the human tragedy we have to say
that is and believe that
uh it's been it's been unbearable in
some ways um
but uh does it present us with
opportunities you were just talking
about opportunities for people that are
technologically minded et cetera
um i found you know that i've been able
to cancel a lot of
in-person meetings and and i've been
having uh to spend more time looking at
data
rather than you know turning
screwdrivers uh might that have a
benefit you know of five years down the
road again
ignoring the awful human consequences do
you see any
bright spot you know covet dividends in
science well i think we'll be in that
sense i think we've learned that a lot
of the travel we've done is unnecessary
um and uh uh we can work more
efficiently etc
so um i think we're not going to go back
to the old normal we're going to go back
to a different one
um but we could have learned those
lessons without having a pandemic
couldn't we don't need to
we could have learned already and we
probably would but we learned those
lessons more
quickly i think than we would have done
before and you talk about the vaccine
and how um you know this is it's really
amazing
who told you about the you know were you
in wuhan a few years ago
a little um but you talk about you know
the instantaneous code for the vaccine
that could be transmitted
around the world and of course a lot of
things have gotten better and tracing
and so forth
one thing was kind of provocative that i
uh must say i was surprised by
towards the end you spoke uh relatively
negatively i would say about um about
things like blockchain and bitcoin
is basically you know you you you say
that they don't really serve a useful
purpose etc
do you still believe that because i can
think of some ways that we could use
blockchain or or bitcoin even in the
context of
you know the virus and and safeguards
etc have you has your opinion changed or
if not
why do you feel that that blockchain is
essentially
uh has negative implications for
uh for society well i mean uh
i i i won't go into detail but but i
think
it's a symptom of what's wrong with
society
that so much of our effort goes into
making things secure you know if you
imagine
what fraction of our economy goes into a
computer security
safety uh air security etc things that
we would not have to do at all
if you could trust each other then
of course traffic you realize how much
of the economy is
unproductive and of course if you think
the economy in general then
uh quite a large factor the financial
sector is
is unproductive it's creeping off money
from the rest of us
and not producing anything so i think
the way
people work um and the uh relative
to different industries um is certainly
far from optimal
and uh um i i don't know about
blockchain may have advantages
um but of course the downside is that
its main motive
is to um uh provide security
which you wouldn't need to bother about
if you could trust people right but of
course you know this from
your association with uh cambridge and
isaac newton that you know isaac newton
was master of the mint
and one of the most vexing problems that
he solved was the problem of coin
clipping
uh and he did so very ingeniously by
putting ridges on coins of precious
metals
i find it very very uh very um
kind of humorous almost that we still
nowadays have these ridges on the edges
of quarters
which used to be a quarter ounce of
silver in america and now we're like
zinc and tin
and aluminum you know and they have no
value whatsoever but we still have these
fluted or ridged edges
that isaac newton uh provided really
solved that age-old problem
uh involving trust and counterfeiting
where coins would be shaved down and the
scrapings would then be accumulated
enough to make a full coin
and that would cause inflation so much
so that in the 1200s as you know uh the
jews
of england were expelled because of this
concern that they were behind this
coin clipping scandal and uh and yet
this was solved by
a physicist essentially um who had a day
job you know coming up with calculus and
gravitation etc
so trust issues go way back i i don't
know that this is uh
this is going to go away
so um the other thing that i found
you know very provocative about this
book is that you you talk
uh about the opportunities and you talk
about um
how we can use uh sort of a type of risk
management approach
to to solve some of these vexing
problems and i guess you know first of
all my
question to you is you know we look at
something like climate change which you
speak very
vociferously about in this book and
convincingly
we'll always have different approaches
to complex problems i don't think
there's a single solution
but um what is it uh you know in your
mind that we would do
if you were emperor lord martin
you know lord in the in the darth vader
sense what would you enact
if you could to start to address this
issue because let me just preface this
by saying
i find it very depressing when we say
you know with there's no solution we
have to cut off everything now
and i remind people that back in 1800s
do you know what the worst problem is
that threatened the financial industry
on wall street in america lord barn
it was the problem of of horse manure
that was gathering on wall street and
preventing
traders from going and peddling their
stocks so
that was solved right it didn't involve
you know making putting horses on a diet
or you know putting diapers on horses uh
it was solved by technology named the
car
and i wonder you know do we not hamper
our children and the imagination of
future
generations by saying we just have to
cut out what we're doing now and
and not really think so much about maybe
you know
big risky things that could have huge
rewards so where do you come down if you
could
if you could by fiat uh may implement
changes what would you start with
well i mean if if we talk about climates
then i think the answer has to lie in
new technology
i mean i i thought most people agree
with that
politicians won't gain much resonance if
they uh promote some hair shirt policy
that people have to
deny things but i think
with new new technology then
i think it is possible for us to move
towards a
system where we can provide affordable
uh carbon free energy for the world and
we ought to prioritize this
and um i've been arguing certainly in
britain um uh
in in britain um we're a small country
and we produce
less than two percent of the world's co2
emissions so
if we uh achieve our declared target of
zero net carbon by 2050
that's only two percent different to the
world right but i would claim that
our country has had more than two
percent of the world's clever ideas
over the last few hundred years and uh
if we um
had a huge investment in um
in clean clean energy and
energy stories batteries and all these
things
so that we could make it easier and more
affordable for say
india and africa to leap frog directed
to clean energy
then we make far more than two percent
difference to world co2 emissions
because of course um um the us and
and us we can probably cut our
um energy needs by a factor of two
without any great hardship
whereas countries like india and africa
they're going to have to expand their
energy needs to have any decent standard
of living
and so not only is the population
growing very fast there
but the per capita consumption is going
to be higher so the most important thing
is to ensure that those countries which
need to develop
can do so in a carbon-free way
and that can be done if the technology
is available and so we should help them
but we i mean the advanced countries
like the us and the uk um
we should help them by um investing very
heavily
in the development of all the things we
need for clean energy
and that would include new nuclear in
this as well um so i think that's
that's the way to do it and it's hard to
think of more inspiring goal for young
engineers
and then to provide clean and affordable
energy
not just for rich countries but so that
uh
um india and africa can develop
a better standard of living so that
that's the line i take and incidentally
um a similar argument applies to food
um because there'll be nine billion
people in the world by 2050
and um they certainly can't all eat as
much beef as present-day americans
it's got to be such a different diet um
that reminds me i'm late for a barbecue
so we should hurry
just kidding and so um
we've got to have high-tech agriculture
um
sustainably intensifiable farming of
vegetables
and also artificial meat that's a great
technology and have been
advances just this week we're speaking
um the
artificial meat and for american
companies being
approved in singapore officially this
first step forward
and these technologies are important so
i'm saying that the technically advanced
countries
um can develop benign technologies in
order to provide
carbon free energy and enough food for
nine billion people in the world by
2050. so
that's the argument that i would give i
did do an interview with an author of a
book
uh chase purdy with an uh who wrote the
book called billion dollar burger about
the quest to produce
lab-grown meat and oh yeah prices come
down from a billion dollars
quite high i want to finish up uh in the
few minutes that we do have left if you
have a few more minutes
lord martin i very much appreciate it uh
i want to ask i'm talking with leonard
milad now who spent a lot of time at
cambridge working with your late
colleague
uh stephen hawking and uh he talks a lot
in in
his most recent book which is kind of
like a biography of stephen hawking's
friendship
with leonard milano and uh i wonder you
know
in terms of the partnerships that you've
had with remarkable people
uh i want to get to lord uh rabbi
jonathan sachs who passed away as well
in a minute but
but first with stephen hawking the kind
of you know collegiality
is i think one or at least um you know
coming together
uh has been lost in covid it it is
possible
to save you know on traveling for a
colloquium but it's not possible to have
the same colloquial kind of interactions
and i wonder if that in your mind is
going to change you know
briskly with the advent of a vaccine or
is this going to permanently
affect science and in in my opinion a
very negative way the
all the authors i've written about and
you as well talk about
your most you know kind of uh delightful
moments or with colleagues
so will that be permanently uh
ratchet it down as we go forward well
i worry very much about this and uh i
think it's true that you know
people like us can probably travel less
when it's just for a meeting or
something like that
but uh thinking back to my own career i
benefited hugely
from being able as a postdoc to um
visit the main centers in the u.s and to
get to know my contemporaries around the
world
and also have a chance to talk
informally to senior people
now if you're postdoc and there's a big
zoom conference
then you may get your 10-minute slot but
you get no feedback
and you get no chance to chat informally
to senior people so
i think whatever we do if we're in
charge of research groups we've got to
make sure that the young people
can travel in the way they used to i
mean the
old people who already have the contacts
uh can probably
um do their work remotely if you know
people already
but the young people need to have the
real contacts
and i think otherwise i would share your
concerns very much indeed
and when we think about um colleagues
outside of our own academic
sort of silo um yes you must have known
uh
rabbi lord jonathan sachs who passed
away can you say something about him
uh and what you know your relationship
might have been like as
as lords yes um
well i didn't know him well i mean i've
read some of his books and i
heard him talk and uh uh he was a very
very clear speaker
uh there's one thing i found it found
very hard to reconcile about him
which was his sort of um general sort of
economical style in general combined
with his very austere
intolerance style doing his job as chief
rabbi
with a famous case when he refused to go
to the funeral
of a more liberal rabbi who was a
national figure it was a scandal at the
time
so i couldn't understand how he combined
uh
his general views with uh being rather
sort of intolerant
um uh in his role as chief rabbi so
that was my perplexed i had about him
yeah um he of course died very suddenly
uh
just just about a month and a half ago
he was um
he was only in his uh just over 70 i
think wasn't he
yeah yeah i think he was 72 very vibrant
and he still has children and his
foundation carry on his important work
one thing he was known for that i do uh
note that you are participating in as
well is social media
and actually you have a twitter account
if i'm not mistaken which i'll link to
in this
um i've had conversations with people in
about six months yes yes yes it's
delightful and i
i do not know
know what's up yeah i will i will put
that on in the show
notes for this episode so people can
follow you and
uh but i've spoken with eminent
scientists paul steinhardt comes to mind
where he views it as a very pernicious
element lenny suskin feels the same way
that
it almost is um it it almost is kind of
um detrimental in the fact that it may
stymie and stifle
new ideas imagine you're you're coming
up with this idea for cmb polarization
in 1968 and you're
you're giving a lecture and and you know
fred hoyle's there jeff burbidge is
there
or they're not there but they tweet out
oh look at this crazy
idea um i mean do you think of it as on
the scientific front obviously in kind
of politics or whatever we could we
could take or leave it but
do you believe it has a net beneficial
uh
effect for scientific progress or do you
think it's detrimental
yes well well i think more generally
outside science i think it's definitely
detrimental i think to
uh um i think social media um that they
hollow out the center and they amplify
extremes which is the reverse
of what we used to have when we had uh
all the news filtered through
responsible journalists so
it's bad but in in science um i think
i'm ambivalent i mean you can do harm
but i think um and again this is a
aspect of what i was saying earlier
about academia becoming less attractive
i mean if people are sort of constrained
that's the only thing that matters is
writing a paper in a learned journal
and they will write a few papers per
year and that's it you know i think
that's pretty i think
would be far better if there was far
more blogging
and interaction and people got credit
for writing good blogs
and um inventing
new courses and things like that um i
think it's unhealthy that in academia
the
the ref read paper is the only thing
that counts
i mean i agree that there's a risk of
lowering lowering standards if you um
value these other things too much you've
got to make clear that
it's a different aspect of one's life
but i think to actually
encourage people who um uh spread
and popularize their science widely and
uh engage with these
issues um it can be done i mean for
instance um in my college in trinity
um uh tim gower who's one of the world's
leading mathematicians
he's had a very effective blog and um
he's done two things
um first he led the campaign against
elsevier you know the
commercial publishers ripping off
academics with the cost of journals
and but also he um got a theorem that
was proved collectively
you know we talked to the beginning
about maths being something which is
done
uh in a solitary way but uh he had some
idea of a theorem that
hadn't been proved and uh he got this
proof by contributing about 70 different
people
on his uh on his blog and website and so
uh to encourage people to do that and
try and make science of social
activities good
and uh i think the social athletic
sounds are what
are most attractive for me i mean i've
enjoyed having collaborators being in a
place where ideas are buzzing
etc it becomes a bit solitary
if you have to work just on one narrow
theme
so the interaction is very very
important
one thing that's uh very prevalent on
social media now are the presence of
artificial intelligent bots and i want
to ask you about artificial intelligence
but maybe a question out of left field
your feelings on the nobel prize
are well known at least to me uh you
criticized my book
not in your blurb thank god but you
criticized my
my book and you you said to me something
like you wish i'd focus more on the
cosmology
and not at all on the nobel prize but i
want to ask you
pertinent to artificial intelligence um
what do you think are the chances that
an artificial intelligence could
either win a nobel prize or create
something that would be perceived in
physics
of being nobel worthy
um well i mean uh uh
i think we had just recently the um
protein folding
success of the deep mind people in that
example
and uh i think it's quite likely
that uh um if string theory is the
correct theory
we may only learn that
through an ai having worked through the
complicated ten dimensional geometry
so you can well imagine that the
geometry could be coded in such a way
that the computer with the advantage of
speed
could explore all the options just in
the way it's done with protein folding
and as i said earlier on uh we'll only
know
that uh the theory is correct if it
spews out
the right mass of the proton or strength
of gravity etc
um but it's quite conceivable to me that
a theory
like string theory involves very very
complicated mathematics
which no human being could do in a
lifetime but which nonetheless could be
solved by the um
by by a machine and uh uh
so um that doesn't mean you give them a
prize but they um
they they are uh would be an aide
without which the work would not be done
so i think that's
completely on the card very good okay i
want to finish up with
questions that i ask of all my uh guests
who come on the show
and they are really centered around big
questions final questions that
in some sense do uh hearken back to sir
arthur c
clarke the namesake of the center that i
co-direct did you know sir arthur
i forgot i didn't i extend emails with
him actually
about the jet of m87 and whether it was
artificial
but i have emails but uh i never
actually met him
okay but uh but his
profiles of the future of course which
is the book we're celebrating
um was a big influence on me yes yeah we
have uh designs to update that
for the future and if so we will include
you i am
of that i have no doubt uh well we'll
get to sir arthur's uh
influence on the final questions after
this first question
uh which i ask of all my guests and that
involves something in hebrew
it's called an ethical will a zava ah
and it it is related in some sense to
alfred nobel who gave away his material
goods but he also
had this kind of heterodox component
that the winners
benefit mankind and that is non-material
immaterial and sort of ethical in nature
and i want to ask you if you were to put
something in your ethical will
not your material will and that
undoubtedly
uh your material will undoubtedly
contains nothing but blockchain and
bitcoin
uh after today's conversation uh but i
want to know what would you
offer in terms of wisdom or values for
not only your biological offspring but
your ideological offspring of which i
count myself as one
yes
well i think going back to my
concerns expressed in the book we've
been talking about
i would say we've got to realize
uh that uh um the inequalities in the
world
need to be reduced does it inequality
within countries
um and inequalities between the wealthy
northern parts
of the world and uh and africa and other
parts
uh we won't have a a peaceful world
unless those are diminished and so i
think any
money i was able to leave etc would go
towards those those causes
to reducing inequalities because it's an
ethical
indictment that the wealth of the two
million richest people
in the world could double the income of
the bottom billion is not happening
i wonder you know because you do mention
that and you mention the
you know income inequality or inc or
just wealth inequality
do you have a practical way to to you
know to administer that you know for
example i look at there's um
michael atherton was a star cricket
player
and he's known for i don't know how do
you say it hitting many centuries or
i i don't follow cricket if you can't
tell but
very wealthy and i just wonder how how
would we do it we have
short stops in america that make 100
times what i make as a university
professor
and they're not even that good uh how do
you go about doing that how do you
distribute income how would you do it
again as
lord of empire of of the planet not just
of the british empire
well it's accepted us it's getting worse
and that the uh the top point one
percent
has been is the only segment of the
population in the us which is better off
in real terms and 20 years ago
i think this is true so something is it
might be going very wrong
and it's almost as bad in my country
and i i think the tax system could do
something about this
very good i don't believe anyone needs
such a huge incentive to keep them
working
so the next one a question i ask my
guest uh does
relate to sir arthur c clarke and that
is connected to
the movie 2001 a space odyssey where
these uh pr
primates or hominids on the plains of
the savannah of
africa come upon this enormous monolith
are you familiar with that scene
yeah so then and then later on it's and
they don't know what to do with it so
they hit it with a bone or you know
something which
makes me hungry for from the barbecue
then i'm missing but uh
but then later on it makes an appearance
on the moon
in space etc and it's clear it's meant
to represent some sort of a time
capsule something that humans are meant
to encounter
when and only when they are able to
benefit from the wisdom or the knowledge
or the or something contained within
and you talk a lot in this book about
potential cataclysms
uh that could occur and i want to remind
you what uh feynman said
a so-called cataclysm question he said
if in some cataclysm all of scientific
knowledge were to be destroyed
and only one sentence passed on to the
next generation of creatures
what statement would contain the most
information in the fewest words
and so he gave an answer about atoms
containing you know being the building
blocks of everything
i want to ask you what would you put on
your monolith a billion year lasting
time capsule
that encapsulates maybe all of science
or all of your accumulated wisdom
perhaps
yes um well i think uh feima's answer is
the one i would give i mean that that's
that's the best but i think to um uh
to to phrase slightly differently if you
ask me
um what uh i've changed in
my views about from being young to being
pretty ancient now um it's to to um
become more amazed at the mystery and
wonder complexity of the universe
and the world especially biological
world because um
you know most people you you look at a
insect or something flying around and
you
think that they're common thing but if
you just think of when the insect
flapped its wings once
all the series of chemical reactions
have to go on
and how it's got to find out who then
the amazing complexity
in even what we think of a very humble
manifest of nature
i don't think when i was young i
appreciated that and i don't think most
people do i think
if you think about animals and plants
you you don't realize that
um if you think about them in the way
that
feynman's recommending which is in terms
of uh
they really are basically chemistry it's
amazing the intricacy that's involved
and so uh i'm more and more um amazed at
the complexity and uh
the wonder and mystery of even simple
things
yeah me too i think about that often and
when i think back to when i was younger
something sad would make me cry or make
me emotional
and nowadays it's much more likely to be
something good
or beautiful as you just mentioned that
you know especially having children
etc that brings me to the state of
emotion because it's so
rare precarious unlikely unentropically
favored that we experience
goodness and i think the pandemic has
taught me that reinforced me that
a notion even more so to appreciate the
the grandeur and the beauty of the world
of course we always have to balance that
against the tendency to worship nature
the gaia hypothesis etc
um but i thought it was interesting i
interviewed uh andrew in the summer
the widow of the late great carl sagan
who endorsed your book as well
she's a writer and producer of the
director of cosmos
and she talked about your ability to be
as a prophet essentially as a prophecy
being a lost art but no better person
than you to take a multi
multi-dimensional meditation of one of
our most distinguished and wise
scientific minds
i couldn't agree with that more and
remind me to tell you her
i asked her what would you put on a
billionaire lasting time capsule and she
said
you mean what did i put on a billion
year lasting time capsule
because she googled yes yes yeah she
recorded her
brainwaves yeah for the voyager one uh
golden disc so-called golden disc i
thought that was amazing
okay the last question i had the honor
of giving the uh
the first carl sagan memorial lecture oh
at cornell who set up uh for the carl
sagan center
and uh and she was there to share it
this was three years ago
oh wonderful yes and her daughter has
recently become an author
and wrote a book for small creatures
such as we and i had
both of them on the show at different
times so it's my first mother-daughter
uh guest appearances on the into the
impossible podcast that's a
quite uh i i call them the first family
of the cosmos no no pun intended
they're great in fact i remember i first
met them when they were doing the first
cosmos series in
about 1980 wasn't it yeah i mean the
cambridge and i was already
there wow yes i would have loved to to
have gotten to know
carl uh unfortunately there aren't many
of them as you point out uh
he was unique almost maybe there's one
other person
but speaking of one other thing i want
to bring up the last of the three
questions
which is sir arthur c clarke had these
many laws and one of which which we open
the show with
is an actual recording of his voice
saying the only uh
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
so that was his some people say it's the
second law i don't really care i call
this first law
his second law is um for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert
which i i have found to be
true in some context and and the last
law is the only way to discover the
limits of the possible
is to venture a little bit beyond them
into the impossible
and you hinted at this before but i want
to ask you just
just in summary what thing about life or
science
mystified you as a young person a 20
year old martin
before you were a lord that you would
give advice to
and what would that advice be uh to your
former self to go
a little bit into the impossible what
would you tell a younger version of
yourself
in terms of life advice yes
well i think what i would tell any sound
is to pick a topic
where new things are happening new
observations new
techniques more path computers um so you
could do things the old guys never had a
chance to do
otherwise you'd be getting stuck on the
things they tried to do and fail so
you've got to
go into a subject that's changing fast
and
uh if i were to predict what that's
going to be
it's going to be the the interface of
computing
and biology and astronomy
and uh and i i would encourage them to
think about
alien life what might be out there and
of course
my most exciting areas in science of
course as you know
is exoplanet research in 10 years we
probably know if there's a biosphere
on some of them and you might learn
something even more exciting so
i would encourage people to work in a
field where there's new techniques
new understanding and that's
as carl would be working on if he was
still alive
one of the most exciting ones absolutely
well
uh lauren martin rhys i want to thank
you so much uh for taking time out of
your very busy schedule
uh you mentioned to me uh in passing uh
that you're working on
another book is that true um
yes what i'm doing one is uh going to be
a sort of self-effacing autobiography
i'm going to sort of uh
talk talk about the big problems of
science include the ones we haven't yet
solved
but try and uh um humanize it not with
my own story which is very boring
but by uh talking about some of the um
eminent scientists i've had a
chance to meet oh wonderful stuff with
iraq and
uh going on to you know freeman dice and
and
many many others so i think i can
personalize it because i've been lucky
to have a chance to meet and learn from
a lot of those people so i'm doing
that i must do another rather boring
book on the organization of science and
how we've got to make sure that science
still provides a vibrant
career for young people and how research
should be organized
and how universities should be changed
and all that so that's a sort of
bureaucratic book on writing well uh
i would love to help out in any way
possible you've been a huge influence on
me
personally as a as a man as a human
being but as a scientist as well
uh anything i could do to ever uh to
help you out
please do let me know and i can't wait
to read the autobiography just
don't be like charles barclay the famous
nba basketball player
in america who said he was taken out of
context
and misquoted in his autobiography i
hope that doesn't happen to you
um thank you so much for going
into the impossible and i look forward
to talking to you when your next book
comes out
i hope you will discover the priority of
gravitational waves
i'll do my best i'll do my best thank
you lord uh
lord i want to encourage my guest to
follow
uh lord martin on twitter he is lord
lord martin rhys i believe on twitter
let me just look that up yes lord martin
reese at lord martin reese
he also has many many books as we've
discussed i want to ask you
all to encourage you all i should say to
please leave a rating and a review on
itunes
of of this podcast into the impossible
subscribe and share it with your friends
so we can get more
great guests we're going to have ray
weiss on the podcast in the next few
weeks joe dunkley
who is a fellow member of the royal
british empire something like that she's
coming on soon giant narlikar i already
mentioned
and then we have john preskill coming up
in the new year and many many
other great guests i'm trying to get and
i
what's that fresco's into ai now isn't
he he is he is he's into ai and quantum
uh quantum entanglement all sorts of
things he's
he's spent the money he got from the bet
with hawking very wisely and we'll talk
about that
uh as roger penrose says you know no
matter what side of a bet you took with
stephen hawking you could always
be sure of winning it because he changed
his mind so much
uh but we'll have on leonard milano as
well who wrote the biography of his
friendship with stephen hawking
and many many other great guests coming
up uh and i want to thank
once again lord martin reece have a
wonderful rest of your night and please
be in touch about your next book i can't
wait to read it
okay thank you brian for having me on
your show
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you